is your hope to stay in this marriage
like the way you said that
well happy belated birthday Kenya Moore
thank you thank you
49 oh you said the number gotta embrace
and live in the number right no I think
so it's it's certainly getting up there
to the big other number so I makes me
excited about next year what do you want
49 to look like oh wow so if I had like
a vision board I would say successful
marriage
lots of love Brooklyn happy healthy
thriving I would say expanding
businesses and fun okay yeah those are
all good positive things yeah I want to
pack a little bit of that but okay you
said loving successful marriage yes last
we knew you and Mark or taking time
apart yes so where do things stand right
now we are still apart but we have well
we are still apart but we are better
friends now than we have been in a very
long time well that's good yeah and we
are co-parenting grade we're going to be
going to counseling soon so I'm
optimistic okay yeah this part of your
life making that decision to take time
apart and figure out what this is gonna
be is about to play out on housewives
that dream how did you guys come to the
realization that that was the right move
for you at that time we didn't have a
lot of conversation about it I think it
was a rash decision that mark made
independently of what I wanted or a
conversation I just believe that when
you're upset you just take natural time
to figure things out and that's not what
he did and he made an announcement and
so that was the end of the story and so
now I think we're just friends again and
talking a lot more and respect
respectful of each other and putting
Brooklyn first the week that the
announcement came out was a little bit
of whiplash we saw you on the Tamron
Hall show this loving family yeah
celebrating the journey to get to
progress and then days later we got
these statements that yes we're
splitting up yes because we had a fight
and instead of giving that time to
breathe and and figure things out after
that you know a decision was made
independent of you independent of me so
that's why that came across that way it
felt like such a blow I think to anybody
who has followed your journey because as
long as you've been on housewives we've
seen you seeking love and chasing love
yes how have you been able to process
this kind of use whiplash again yeah and
mentally where are you at right now
I really appreciate the people that are
following my journey and the viewers and
the fans they've all been rooting for me
and I think it broke my heart to and it
broke their heart when that announcement
was made but show had not started they
didn't know about the struggles we were
having and I was very transparent about
it once the baby came things just you
know the stress of life just really kind
of made our relationship deteriorate and
we couldn't find our way back to it
but all in all I still think that a rash
decision was made where I am right now
is just in how I have been coping with
it it's just being the strong person
that I know to be I sort of
compartmentalize things in my life and I
don't let anything destroy me I have the
most amazing daughter anyone can ask for
so every day it's just a joy to me you
know yes my marriage is falling apart
but look at this beautiful daughter that
I have like her smile her energy her
love that she gives me I not be happier
I met you I think four or five years ago
yeah you are sitting before me today a
different person and I think a lot of
that has to do with baby Brooklyn I
think so too being a mom soften to you
it makes you look at things differently
and I just have a different appreciation
for life in all things that I'm living
for it means that is my legacy
is how I raise this child how we raised
Brooklyn is your hope to stay in this
marriage I like the way you said that I
would like to stay in this marriage
because I still have love for my husband
but it has to change a lot of things
will have to change communication number
one it has to always be respectful
communication even when you're upset
when you're hurt and when you're you
know angry or whatever the emotions you
might be feeling at the time you you
have to always keep in mind that you are
partnership and you cannot take some
things back once they're sad or done
they cannot be you know taken back and I
think that one of our biggest issues is
the communication and then where it goes
when you're not having a healthy fight I
think being vulnerable you know throwing
away ego and pride is very important
because you can't really get to the
balls of how someone really feels unless
they're able to like just put everything
out on the table and be really raw and
vulnerable
and and I just think the last part of it
is just loving knowing that you're in
this partnership and you both want to
make it work and have a beautiful family
I mean we have that and I would hate to
lose it are we still living half in New
York half in Atlanta no we're separated
now okay so yeah he's still in New York
and I'm in Atlanta most of the time but
I do travel there and we spend time
together in the big picture everything
works out would that require a full-time
move to one city over the other I think
absolutely I think for a relationship to
be successful if you have one residence
or ten you have to move at the same time
maybe a week apart it would be okay but
you have to live under the same roof do
you have any inkling of whether that
would be New York or Atlanta it won't be
New York okay well you know when you
first got married and you were spending
more time in New York people really
wanted you on Real Housewives of I know
I think I would be good when Bethenny
was there I think Bethenny and I would
have had been a really good must-see TV
oh sure it was a journey to get to
Brooklyn - do you want to have more kids
yeah I you know I really do I see
Brooklyn and she is the life of the
party we're on the plane and she's
walking down the aisles hi hi hi you
know lady takes after her mom like it's
all about her she's just like hosting
everyone on the plane so that was that's
um interesting to see her be so outgoing
and special and she loves people and she
loves other little kids and I would just
really like to see her with a play man
growing up I think she won't be a great
big sister to someone and I don't know
fingers crossed when will you show
Brooklyn episodes of Housewives oh never
never all right what if she discovers of
them herself she goes on Hulu and finds
your first season
hopefully we will have better parental
locks Bible
[Music]